I come from a lower-middle-class part of Honolulu...
...and I don't want to paint a picture of total poverty,...
...just overcoming horrendous conditions because that's not true.
I had a very happy lower-middle-class upbringing.
I'm third-generation Japanese-American.
My family came over from Japan because of the lack of economic opportunity.
And you could also make the case that my family came over because, at that time,...
...males in Japan were conscripted.
So, you were drafted to go fight in China,...
...so you could make the case that I come from a family of draft dodgers.
And the lesson that I learned here is that,...
...you know, my family made a very big decision.
They didn't just change jobs or change streets or change prefectures,...
...they changed countries.
And the wisdom I got from that is, you know, change a losing game.
If you're in a game that you cannot win,...
...the odds are stacked against you, then change it.
And in their case, they left Japan and moved to Hawaii.
Now, it's not like they moved to Hawaii to become investment bankers.
They moved to Hawaii to pick sugarcane.
So, pick sugarcane, first generation, second generation,...
...real estate broker, state senator.
My father, third generation, goes to Stanford, Silicon Valley, tech, the whole thing.
So, I'm the third generation, but the first generation,...
...the generation that moved to Hawaii is what changed the game.